salut france 3 bienvenue à la maison
j'allais commencer à travailler
suivez-moi
voici mon pote nolan c'est celui qui me
suit lors de mes compétitions et voici
mon choix de travail c'est là où je
m'entraîne
c'est ce qui s'appelle faire une entrée
fracassante
inconnu dans le petit monde de l'ispor
il y a un nom encore julien faire balle
plus connu sous le nom de fu may a
décroché coup sur coup en 2021 le titre
de meilleur joueur de france et d'europe
sur ce jeu de football je pense que je
réalise pas parce que tout s'enchaîne en
fait et à tous qui s'enchaînent super
vite et au final après bah quand tu
gagnes ce genre de tournoi du coup tu es
tu es attendu aux autres et tu es obligé
de te remettre au travail j'ai pas le
temps de savourer le trophée on va dire
et de me dire ça y est
tranquille j'ai envie de de travailler
encore plus pour finir champion du monde
c'est ce qui me reste
sur ces images julien gère
tranquillement sa finale européenne un
succès qui lui a permis de remporter 100
mille dollars ici il reçoit le titre de
meilleur joueur de france des mains de
jean pierre papin désormais julien a
arrêté ses études et a rejoint une
équipe professionnelle ça ressemble
beaucoup à un joueur professionnel de
foot on est dans une équipe on a un
salaire on a des coéquipiers on a un
coach on a un staff
dans l'équipe ya des gens qui s'occupent
de nous ne sait pas pour gérer plein de
faisans de nuit et pour le soutenir
durant ces compétitions julien compte
sur son ami d'enfance témoin privilégié
de ses exploits mais je pense que lui
même il réalise pas et même moi parce
qu'on est dedans encore et ça sera dans
des années qu'on se rendra compte parce
que comme on a eu des exemples comme
ceux de la nec etc c'était des exemples
d
idole un petit peu et aujourd'hui et là
il a réussi à réaliser ça en l'espace
d'un an c'est incroyable la suite le
champion d'europe attend impatiemment la
sortie du prochain opus et devenir
champion du monde en 2022